One of the reasons that it is crucial that
everybody just stay home is that many people
have the virus but have no symptoms or almost
no symptoms and what are sometimes called
asymptomatic or sometimes maybe more accurately,
subclinical cases.
And the question has been, to what degree
is this a thing?
We've heard numbers thrown out that suggest
anywhere from as little as 5 or 10 percent
of the population that's infected all the
way up to 50 percent may be asymptomatic or
at least subclinical.
And Iceland has been testing this pretty precisely
with some large numbers of tests which they
can do thanks to their small population.
Iceland's total population is under 400000
people total.
And the latest results from a study of 9000
people in Iceland is that as many as half
of those infected have no idea because they
have no symptoms noticeable enough for them
to perceive those.
So what Iceland did is Iceland did a test
of about five, has had so far tested about
5 percent of its population, just pretty broad
testing.
That's about 18000 tests.
And then there's been a separate testing protocol
which has tested 9000 people who chose to
participate.
Fewer than 1 percent of the tests came back
positive, meaning that the percentage of the
population, in fact, that is believed to be
under 1 percent.
But half of the positive tests were people
who said, I never had any symptoms.
I've felt fine the entire time.
And yet they if they're not home, which many
in Iceland are not, because Iceland actually
has not done the stay at home part very seriously.
You were out spreading the disease.
If you are out and about, this is why everybody's
got to stay home.
The asymptomatic spread appears to be absolutely
huge.
Now, understand that even though this this
nine thousand person test was randomized,
it is made up of people who are choosing to
get tested.
And that could impact the results in some
way.
But imagine it's not 50 percent and it's 20
percent or 15 percent.
If 15 percent of the cases that are out there
are asymptomatic and people don't know it,
that's why it's important to stay home regardless
of how you feel, regardless of your age or
anything else.
We're working together.
We're trying to get past this.
And this result also reinforces the eventual
importance of having a simple at home antibody
test, which could answer the question, did
I ever have coronavirus?
Now, the FDA did yesterday approved the first
antibody test, the serology test.
It is a blood test, but it's not a pinprick
test.
It's a vein test.
You would.
Once this gets rolled out, you would have
to go into a lab to have the tests done.
How many of those tests were likely to do
under that protocol to test the population?
I don't really know.
But we are going in the direction of being
able to test for antibodies, which is a very
good thing.
Often when people post to social media and
say, you know, I think I might have had this
a month ago, a month and a half ago, whatever.
It's very popular to shame those people and
to say stop being dramatic.
Almost everybody who has it has a fever.
And that's true of symptomatic patients who
have been tested.
If you don't have symptoms, you obviously
don't have a fever.
And when we get eventually to the point where
we can start opening back up a little bit.